jubel bei der cdu die partei von
ministerpräsident läuft bleibt in
sachsen anhalt deutlich stärkste kraft
klar vor der afd
die fdp ist wohl zurück im landtag land
in sorge in großbritannien breitet sich
die besonders ansteckende indische
variante des corona virus immer weiter
aus und land unter heftige unwetter
haben in großen teilen deutschlands
chaos ausgelöst
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen an diesem wahlsonntag sport
gibt es auch in der sendung mit polizei
hallo schön genannt das von der afg
angestrebte beben in sachsen anhalt ist
ausgeblieben die cdu von
ministerpräsident reiner haseloff hat
das rennen um die stärkste kraft im land
klar für sich entschieden
die afg bleibt auf platz zwei
enttäuschend sind die ergebnisse für die
mitregierenden spd und grünen
die fdp schafft es wohl erstmals nach
zehn jahren wieder in den landtag
matthias fornoff ist in unserem wald
studio in magdeburg matthias wie sehen
die aktuellen zahlen aus
endlich zu 19 uhr gibt es frische zahlen
hier ist die zweite hochrechnung danach
kommt die cdu auf 35,5 prozent und
gewinnt deutlich dazu da die afg auf
23,1 mit verlusten die linke mit 10,9
prozent und deutlichen verlusten
die spd 8,1 prozent also einstellig und
nochmal mit verlusten 2,5 punkte
die grünen 6 prozent mit geringfügigen
zu gewinnen die fdp 6,7 prozent ist
wieder drin im landtag nach zehn jahren
und die freien wähler haben es nicht
geschafft bleiben bei 3% jetzt schauen
wir mal auf die sitzverteilung im
landtag von magdeburg 83 sitze gibt es
da mindestens es wird aber wohl überhang
und ausgleichsmandaten geben das
tangiert aber nicht das kräfteverhältnis
also können wir damit rechnen die cdu
kommt demnach auf 33 sitze die afc auf
21 linke zehn spd 7 grüne 6 und fdp 6
und die absolute mehrheit läge dann bei
42 sitzen wir gucken mal was das für das
regieren hieß die amtierende kenia
regierung aus cdu spd und grünen käme
auf 46 sitze und damit deutlich über die
42 die man mindestens braucht wäre die
fdp mit in der regierung statt den
grünen die sogenannte deutschland
koalition ging es ebenfalls auf 46 und
es würde reichen
jamaica cdu grüne fdp 45 sitze auch das
würde reichen
eine ehemals große koalition muss man
sagen aus cdu und spd aber würde es
nicht schaffen das sind 40 sitze ein
wort noch zur wahl
bedingung die lag ziemlich genau so wie
vor fünf jahren bei 61 prozent
dankeschön matthias fornoff die frage
wer mit wem wird auch die
spitzenkandidaten spitzenkandidatinnen
umtreiben die sind jetzt bei bettina
schausten und unserem landes
korrespondenten andreas weise versammelt
bettina zumindest ministerpräsident
haseloff ist ja überglücklich wir vorhin
sagte die überglückliche alle sind hier
versammelt ich muss nochmal einmal zur
erklärung sagen natürlich mit abstand
den halten wir pandemie bedingt dann
doch noch ein mitarbeiten haseldorf hat
das rennen gemacht mit deutlichem
abstand zur afg sie können sich
bestätigt sehen und sehen bestätigt auch
ihre koalition mit der sie sachsen
anhalt hier regieren kenia koalition
das ist richtig wir stabil regiert bei
allen ecken und kanten die wir im
täglichen vollzug sicherlich auch hatten
hat das ganze fünf jahre gehalten und
hat gezeigt dass demokratische parteien
in der mitte auch eine koalition ruhig
führen können auch wenn sie so noch
nicht erprobt wurde in deutschland das
war die erste in deutschland die wir
gemacht haben und die karre costa zum
einerseits und auch die ganze zeit über
die koalition nach rechts hin hat das
denke ich mal
auch noch mal bestand wir wissen dass
das wahlergebnis abwarten ist hier noch
die briefwahlstimmen und da muss man
schauen welche optionen sich ergeben
dann wird wirklich in aller sachlichkeit
nur danach geschaut was ich das landgut
ich denke wir sind nicht gut beraten uns
irgendwie instrumentalisieren zu lassen
von bundesthemen oder von anderer
bundestagswahl was könnte dort
konstellation ist mäßig günstig bei
denen oder bei denen sein
es geht um sachsen anhalt und deswegen
werden wir miteinander sprechen und über
gerechten spitzenkandidat der afd
sie hatten schon als ziel platz eins
ausgegeben haben leicht verloren sind
sie enttäuscht heute
ich hatte das ziel nicht ausgegeben ich
habe immer gesagt zwischen 326 prozent
würde ich mir wünschen ich bin überhaupt
nicht enttäuscht ich bin froh darüber
wir sind volkspartei im osten anderer
sind es nicht mehr wir haben es die
wähler der linken zurück geholt die
arbeiter das wollten wir schaffen und
deswegen bin ich hier sagt sie
die spitzenkandidatin der linken vor
fünf jahren bereits kräftig verloren
jetzt geht die talfahrt weiter
und man hat das gefühl die linke ist
wird nicht mehr wahrgenommen als
statthalter deutscher interessen warum
konnten sie den abwärtstrend nicht
stoppen
also ich bedaure natürlich das ergebnis
was wir heute eingefahren haben nehmen
aber auch zur kenntnis dass es auch teil
des der der cdu kampagne cdu oder
barbarei ist also wir haben da
insbesondere spd grüne und auch wir als
linke haben da erheblich verloren
ich habe das für verantwortungslos
gehalten weil sachsen anhalt ist kein
nazi land der ministerpräsident war sie
aber nicht zu schade um macht zu
erhalten uns genau an dieser ecke zu
schieben und ich erwarte jetzt von ihm
das jetzt zeitnah eine landesregierung
bildet und nicht so wie schon von der
cdu im landtag geäußert dass man noch
warten wolle bis nach der bundestagswahl
wo wir dann alle nicht wissen ob er
nicht doch möglicherweise diesen
rechtskonservativen weg geht also da
sehe ich jetzt seine verantwortung und
auch vor allem nach dem was hier in den
letzten tagen seinerseits auch vollzogen
worden ist ich bin gespannt wie er das
macht nachdem er gestern erst noch
geäußert hat dass alle die nicht cdu
gewählt haben diesen land geschadet
haben
das ist demokratiefeindlich aber das ist
jetzt seinen job darin wie sie es gerne
haben wollten jetzt der wahlkampf wird
noch fortgesetzt nehmen wir hier war
andreas kapelle spitzenkandidaten der
spd wieder verloren diesmal einstellig
und das obwohl sie eigentlich in der
regierungspartei relativ gute kritiken
bekommen in der regierungsarbeit gute
kritiken bekommen haben was für
konsequenzen müssen sie jetzt daraus
ziehen
ich stelle einfach fest dass auch das
ergebnis der spd ein ergebnis ist mit
dem wir nicht zufrieden sein können es
aber tatsächlich auch dem umstand
geschuldet ist dass es hier im land auch
in den prognosen eine polarisierung
zwischen cdu und fdp gegeben hat und ich
weiß dass viele wählerinnen und wähler
überlegt haben wenn sie denn tatsächlich
wählen können um die afg stärkste kraft
hier im land zu verhindern und deshalb
finde ich es demokratisch betrachtet gut
dass die stimmen bei der cdu gelandet
sind für meine partei ist es
aber sehr sehr bedauerlich ich zähle
aber gleichzeitig auch noch auf die
briefwähler
das heißt am ende des abends marktes
ergebnis noch anders aussehen als
aktuell
cornelia lüddemann von den grünen
regierungsmitglied das hat ihr nicht
genutzt
sie konnten jedenfalls nicht zu legen
wie man das vielleicht hätte erwarten
können wenn man im bund eine
kanzlerkandidaten aufstellt warum hat es
hier nicht geklappt und wir wollen sie
vor allem sicherstellen dass sie weiter
in der regierung mit dabei sind
es ist zunächst einmal will ich
feststellen dass wir dazu gewonnen haben
wir sind in einem aus deutschen
bundesland dass es traditionell nicht
einfach für die grünen wir hätten uns
natürlich gewünscht dass wir noch
deutlich mehr zu stimmenzugewinne haben
um den klimaschutz auch in einer
nächsten regierung deutlich stärker
vorantreiben zu können
ich hoffe dass es nach auszählung der
briefwahlstimmen noch ein bisschen nach
oben geht aber tatsächlich hätte ich mir
mehr für klimaschutz an der stelle
gewünscht
lydia hüskens spitzenkandidatin der fdp
zehn jahre hat es gedauert jetzt sind
sie wieder im landtag
welche rolle wollen sie im landtag
vielleicht sogar auch in der
landesregierung spielen ja welche rolle
wir spielen können werden wir sehen
immer das wahlergebnis haben und
zumindest die umfragen zeigen ja dass es
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten gibt da
ist für uns dann wichtig welches projekt
welche ziele hat man für sachsen anhalt
wie können wir 600 voranbringen
und wenn wir überzeugt sind dass das
dann auch einen sinnvollen überlegungen
sind dann sind ja auch bereit mit
verantwortung zu übernehmen
vielen dank so wir haben gut drei monate
bis zur bundestagswahl von daher
haseldorf wissen auch sie das hier heute
sehr genau aus sachsen-anhalt geschaut
wird was für ein signal sagen sie geht
richtung bund richtung armin laschet von
diesem wahlabend aus wurde erstmal muss
man als cdu sorgen wenn wir geschlossen
arbeiten und geschlossener auftreten mit
der csu gemeinsam kann man erfolgreich
sein das ist eigentlich die botschaft
geschlossenheit kann im prinzip das
rezept sein damit man auch die
bundestagswahl gewinnt auf der anderen
seite muss man eben auch die
spezifischen besonderheiten des
jeweiligen landes einer jeweiligen
region auch im bundestagswahlkampf
sehr genau zur kenntnis nehmen und da
gibt es im osten spezifika wenn man sich
nicht richtig erkennt und aufgreift
durchaus dann zum problem werden können
wenn man also wahlergebnis am 26
september sieht also wäre ihr rad den
ostdeutschland nicht zu vergessen im
bundestag kann ich sie richtig verstehe
ich schlage aber in österreich schon
wird man kanzler um ostdeutschland wird
verhindert obmann kanzler wird soweit
unsere spitzenkandidaten runde aus
magdeburg heute abend zurück ins studio
zu ballweg dankeschön sie hans gehört
sachsen anhalt sie haben es gehört das
ist der letzte wahltermin vor der
bundestagswahl im september also eine
art ultimativer stimmungstest besonders
aufmerksam verfolgen entsprechend die
parteizentralen in der hauptstadt die
einlaufenden ergebnisse hier die ersten
reaktionen von verlieren und gewinnen
aus berlin
es ist ein persönlicher sieg von reiner
haseloff aber des ganzen teams der cdu
in sachsen-anhalt wir haben auch als cdu
deutschlands gemeinsam mit den freunden
freundin gekämpft insofern ein starker
kandidat ein klares profil der mitte und
geschlossenheit das war ausschlaggebend
es gibt mittlerweile in sachsen anhalt
nur noch zwei volksparteien das ist die
cdu und das ist die afd
also das zeigt doch eigentlich ganz klar
was die was die bürger in sachsen anhalt
wollen eine regierung aus cdu und fdp
haben deutlich an stimmen verloren und
haben unsere wahlziele nicht erreicht
wir sind immer auf einem niveau das wir
uns dass uns natürlich nicht zufrieden
stellen kann und deswegen ist es ein
enttäuschendes ergebnis für uns das ist
kein schönes ergebnis wir hatten uns
deutlich mehr erhofft es gab viele
menschen in sachsen anhalt die gerade
bei diesem kopf an kopf rennen zwischen
haseloff und der hfg was die letzten
tage ja sichtbar war da haben viele dann
gesagt dann wählen wir jetzt den
haseloff weil wir nicht wollen dass die
fdp in sachsen anhalt stärkste kraft
führt an tags wahlen sind immer sehr
landesspezifisch das haben wir auch in
allen vorangegangenen landtagswahlen
gesehen deswegen die bundestagswahl
da geht es um was anderes da geht es um
eine erneuerung unseres landes nach der
pandemie
aber klar ist wir haben uns in sachsen
anhalt ein bisschen mehr erwünscht auch
wenn wir im vergleich zu fünf jahren
zugelegt haben nach über zehn jahren
werden jetzt wieder freie demokraten im
landtag von sachsen anhalt vertreten
sein
im heimatland von hans dietrich genscher
gibt es nun wieder eine liberale
parlamentsfraktion und darüber freuen
wir uns über die landesgrenzen von
sachsen-anhalt hinaus die wahl in
sachsen anhalt gleich nach uns geht es
weiter mit der berichterstattung live
aus magdeburg alle entwicklungen gibt es
auch online in unserem live blog zur
wahl in der zdf- heute- app
gesundheitsminister sparen hat die
vorwürfe um angeblich minderwertige
corona schutzmaske zurückgewiesen die
masken seien intensiv geprüft worden und
hätten alle nötigen eigenschaften
spd und opposition hatten ihm
vorgeworfen er habe unbrauchbare masken
an bedürftige verteilen wollen
trotz schwarz erklärung hagelt es weiter
scharfe kritik klaus brodbeck
es geht immer weiter jens spahn und die
pannen in der pandemie und der druck
wächst rücktritt oder rauswurf des
ministers liegt die spd heute dem
koalitionspartner nahe
herr laschet ist gefragt wir wissen was
wir zu tun hätten jetzt ist die frage
ist es für die cdu ausreichend wenn man
merkt da kommt einer mit masken skandal
dann kommt einer mit einem zweiten
masken skandal
dann klappt das impfen nicht dann klappt
das texten nicht dass man sich jetzt mal
fragen muss ist die cdu damit
einverstanden dass sie diese minister im
kabinett hat oder nicht
cdu-chef laschet jedoch will sich dazu
heute auch auf anfrage nicht äußern
spahns ministerium bringt ein papier in
umlauf um die vorwürfe zu entkräften
sparen selbst hat der gt spd dass einige
nun bewusst obdachlose und menschen mit
behinderung verunsichern um stimmung zu
machen sagt mehr über den zustand der
spd als über die qualität der masken aus
unbrauchbare masken für eine milliarde
euro sparen ministerium soll versucht
haben fehler zu vertuschen etwa durch
verteilung an bedürftige
die opposition aber auch der
sozialverband vdk erschüttert die
aufgabe des bundesgesundheitsministers
ist doch gerade diese gruppen besonders
gut zu schützen
die sind doch nicht die resterampe für
fehlinvestitionen aus dem
das gesundheitsministerium ist das maß
ist voll das war jetzt eben nicht nur
der erste tropfen sondern ein riesen
schlug der das fass zum überlaufen
gebracht hat und das muss jetzt erst mal
konsequenzen geben
jens spahn und der umgang mit maske zu
beginn der pandemie probleme damit so
scheint es gibt es bis heute
wir schauen auf die korona zahlen das
robert koch institut meldet 2440
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden das
sind 1412 weniger als vergangenen
sonntag
außerdem kamen innerhalb eines tages 74
todesfälle hinzu die bundesweite sieben
tage inzidenz sinkt auf 24,7
großbritannien wollte eigentlich in gut
zwei wochen seine corona beschränkungen
vollständig aufheben
doch jetzt steigen die infektionszahlen
wieder anfang mai lag die sieben tage
incidents bei 23 nun ist sie fast
doppelt so hoch sorge bereitet vor allem
das sich die ansteckende hre indische
variante immer weiter ausbreitet das in
hallein hat mir nichts wird unversucht
gelassen um die ausbreitung der
indischen virusvariante einzudämmen
dort wo sie besonders verbreitet ist wie
hier im bett wird rufen helfer an der
haustür zum testen und impfen auf und im
ganzen land wird das ohnehin
anerkanntermaßen sehr erfolgreiche im
programm noch einmal beschleunigt ab
morgen können sich offiziell alle unter
30 jährigen ihre erste dosis
verabreichen lassen vom britischen
gesundheitsminister heute dann der
versuch die lage nüchtern einzuordnen
geschätzt 40 prozent ist diese variante
anstecken das macht uns allen das leben
etwas schwerer
die infektionen steigen leicht an die
gute nachricht lautet dass die zahl der
krankenhausaufnahme weitgehend gleich
bleibend ist und betroffen sind
überwiegend nicht geimpfte die
vorliegenden daten seien jedoch nicht
ausreichend man einige wissenschaftler
und warnt vor einer baldigen aufhebung
der korona beschränkungen am 21
juni als tag der offnen festzuhalten
wäre ein fehler wir haben in den
vergangenen 15 monaten schmerzhaft
erfahren steht handeln heißt auf zu spät
erhöhte vorsicht fordert die regierung
von diesen britischen reisenden bereits
jetzt ein
tausende brechen ihren portugal urlaub
ab um eine ab dienstag geltenden zwangs
quarantäne bei rückkehr nach england zu
entgehen mit turbulenzen und kehrtwenden
ist diesen sommer wohl weiterhin zu
rechnen
überlastete krankenhäuser kaum
sauerstoff in indien war die pandemie
lage noch vor wenigen wochen
katastrophal
täglich sterben tausende menschen
hunderttausende steckten sich an
inzwischen gehen die zahlen deutlich
zurück einige regionen bereiten erste
lockerungen vor
bereits ab morgen dürfen etwa geschäfte
und restaurants wieder öffnen
in der türkei sorgt ein ehemaliger mafia
boss für aufsehen der per haftbefehl
gesuchte sedat kkr erhebt auf youtube
schwere vorwürfe gegen die
regierungsmitglieder seine videos werden
millionenfach geklickt für
staatspräsident erdogan wird das
zunehmend zum problem aus istanbul jörg
brase
heute morgen ging said peters neues
video online und wieder schauen
millionen zu
der mafia-boss auf der flucht plaudert
über bestechung drogenkartelle
auftragsmorde über dunkle geschäfte von
hohen partei und regierungsfunktionäre
hauptzielscheibe ist innenminister
schünemann soll den pk mit mafia geld
unterstützt haben will
du wirst vor den obersten gerichtshof
gestellt du hast keine chance ich habe
alles vorbereitet ich werde auspacken
ich habe die beweise ich mache dich
fertig der innenminister gerät unter
druck
er soll die zusage pk können in die
türkei zurückkehren gebrochen haben
der übt nun aus dem exil rache wochen
lang schwieg präsident erdogan zu der
internet-kampagne bevor er sich dann
doch hinter seoul gestellt
dabei habe jemanden der friede und die
sicherheit in unserem land nicht wir
stehen zu unserem innenminister in
seinem kampf gegen kriminelle
banden und terroristen und wir werden
das auch weiterhin tun ich gestehe über
können nach umfragen aber glaubt eine
mehrheit in der türkei dass an den
vorwürfen des mafia boss ist etwas dran
ist dass es verbindungen gibt zwischen
politik und organisierter kriminalität
das so glauben beobachter könnte auch
dem image des präsidenten schaden
die akp hat an zustimmung verloren und
ich denke dass vorwürfe werden diesen
trend verstärken
auch wenn es die stammwähler der akp
nicht beeinflussen wird
die opposition im türkischen parlament
fordert die staatsanwaltschaft solle
piquets vorwürfe untersuchen die
strafermittler aber suchen vor allem
sedat picker selbst in mexiko findet die
größte abstimmung in der geschichte des
landes statt etwa 20.000 ämter werden
neu besetzt darunter parlamentssitze und
bürgermeister ämter mehr als 90
millionen mexikaner sind zur stimmabgabe
berechtigt der wahlkampf war geprägt von
zahlreichen gewalttaten mindestens 90
politiker wurden ermordet
dahinter werden rivalisierende
drogenkartelle vermutet im deutschen
innenstädten haben autoraser schwere
unfälle provoziert etwa am kudamm in
berlin nach einer verfolgungsjagd mit
der polizei stieß dort ein cabrio mit
mehreren einsatzwagen und einem
unbeteiligten auto zusammen
resultat fünf verletzte in dortmund
raste ein pkw in eine hauswand dessen
fahrer hatte sich mit einem anderen ein
rennen geliefert
der mann und seine beiden mitfahrer
wurden schwer verletzt
heftiger regen gewitter hagelschläge das
wetter hält in diesen tagen sehr
unliebsame überraschungen bereit
punktuell kommt es in fast ganz
deutschland zur ausnahmezuständen ohne
vorwarnung denn die heftigen
niederschläge und stürme lassen sich
nicht präzise vorhersagen
die schäden sind beträchtlich christoph
distel von jetzt auf gleich zietz
bedrohlich zu haben so oder ähnlich die
meisten in diesem wochenende erlebt und
dann glück oder pech gehabt glück kurzer
schauer pech so ein wolkenbruch wie in
weißbach in sachsen
erst liefen die felder voll dann der
dorfbach und trotz improvisierter
barriere aus biertischen
schließlich auch die gaststätte sowieso
der falsche zeitpunkt aber hier gleich
doppelt wir hatten gerade eben die
eröffnung gemacht dann lassen doch noch
genauer auch in rüdesheim bei bad
kreuznach musste all das wasser irgendwo
hin immer bergab mit aller wucht die
schäden sind noch unübersichtlich im
gegensatz zu bad abbach in niederbayern
nicht steiler berg gelegen
sicherheitshalber gibt es einen ablauf
graben und doch kam das wasser nicht zum
ersten mal überhaupt nicht häufig
spritzen autos abgesoffen wohnungen
überschwemmt das wochenende hatte es
auch in bünde nördlich von bielefeld in
sich bei familie düsterwald wurde auch
der wiener stahl überschwemmt schwere
lage menschliche lösung das erste kam
die hühner im badezimmer unter spannende
formel 1 sebastian vettel holt den
ersten podestplatz in seinem aston
martin
nach einer grandiosen aufholjagd wird er
zweiter beim großen preis von
aserbaidschan
hinter dem mexikaner sergio perez im red
bull
endlich mal wieder auf dem podium für
vettel ein altes vertrautes gefühl von
platz 11 gestartet überholte viertel
unter anderem charlie klären ferrari
oder auch den staaten kircher sie im
alfa taugen dem lange führenden
maxvorstadt beim red bull kostete ein
geplatzter hinterreifen den sieg mein
neustart rollte lewis hamilton zu viel
und fuhr aus den führenden rängen
sebastian vettel dagegen erreichte in
seinem aston martin als zweiter hinter
perez das ziel und durfte endlich mal
wieder die korken teilen
im spiel um wm-platz drei verliert die
deutsche eishockey-nationalmannschaft in
lettland 1 zu 6 gegen die usa
dennoch ist rang 4 für den deutschen
eishockey-bund das beste abschneiden
seit 2010 im zehnten turnierspiel will
deutschland einfach nichts glücken
selbst bei überzahl geht der puck ins
tor
den usa dagegen stecken den frust über
ihr verlorenes halbfinale locker weg
drei tore in gut vier minuten die mit
abstand höchste deutsche niederlage bei
dieser wm
nach den großartigen leistungen der
vortage scheint das team von tony söder
rolle auch mental restlos erschöpft
immerhin kommen noch zum 1 5-endstand
aber sechs zu eins für die usa
und jetzt wieder jubeln die
fußballerinnen des fc bayern münchen
feiern die vierte deutsche meisterschaft
der vereinsgeschichte
am letzten spieltag gewinnt die
mannschaft gegen eintracht frankfurt 4 0
titelverteidiger wolfsburg wird zweiter
und am finaltag der final stets um die
letzten deutschen meistertitel malaika
me hamburg setzt trotz formschwäche ihre
siegesserien fort mit mäßigen 662
sichert sich die weltmeisterin in
braunschweig den vierten deutschen
meistertitel nacheinander
patrick hausding rechts und timo bartl
gewinnen den titel im turm
synchronspringen in berlin mit der
bestleistung von 436 62 punkten und das
war der sport
dankeschön rudi kern die woche startet
mit sehr ungleich verteiltem wetter
frust und wetter freunden im emsland an
der ostsee und an der oder erscheint
morgen die sonne sonst gibt es schauer
südlich des mains auch gewitter örtlich
mit starkregen 17 bis 24 im nordosten
bis 28 grad bei 19 bis 28 grad gibt es
auch in den nächsten tagen schauer und
gewitter die meisten im süden marietta
slomka analysiert die wahl im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn wir danken
für ihr interesse wünschen noch einen
schönen sonntagabend